porque eu sou um ser social papo reto
cmm social
eu escolhi o curso de publicidade e
propaganda por justamente ser uma
ferramenta da comunicação
o nome do curso era comunicação social
com habilitação em publicidade e
propaganda
mas com o passar do tempo durante a
faculdade assim eu passei no vestibular
eu percebi que de social a propaganda
não tinha quase nada nos estágios no dia
a dia dos trabalhos
eu acabei me afastando da sua história a
gente não quer o show sabe não rola o
sentimento
eu fiquei longe por 11 anos e há mais ou
menos uns quatro anos atrás eu conheci
luiza era faxineira e eu a convidei para
fazer faxina na minha casa
a gente trocou zap claro a disappear
naquela época não tinha áudio e o
desafio e também não fazia ligação com a
gente se comunicavam apenas teoricamente
por mensagem de texto
era o que tinha mas a luiza gente era
analfabeta analfabeta e aí você deve
estar se perguntando como é que elas
conversavam
como é que a história se dá à luz já
conversava comigo por ele hoje ela me
cumprimentar o ator é moggi ela me dava
bom dia e ela perguntava se e acontecer
a faxina naquele dia e eu respondia por
ano hoje também a publicidade propaganda
gera muito resíduo social as nossas
vidas e ela sempre utilizou a ferramenta
da exclusão
aquele corpo impossível de se atingir
aquela viagem caríssima que a gente não
consegue pagar em 60 meses
aquele carro absoluto que os jogadores
de futebol só conseguiam comprada por 56
anos de carreira
o resíduo social gerado pela publicidade
movimentou
nossos sentimentos e emoções até a nossa
forma de conduzir a vida por muitas
décadas a publicidade colaborou com os
problemas e com as questões sociais no
que diz respeito à padronização de
pessoas ea gente sem perceber esse
movimento acabou rejeitando pessoas que
não entrava dentro de um padrão que a
gente acreditava também ser o ideal
não estou aqui querendo dizer sei que a
publicidade ea mazinha da história não
a gente sabe que a sociedade tem as suas
mazelas
a gente sabe das dores da sociedade mas
a publicidade colaborou com isso ea
gente acabou se permitindo isso o que
sugerir ou nas relações o que é que isso
foi mentor no nosso dia a dia a gente
acabou multiplicando o que é publicidade
e propaganda por muitas décadas
desenvolveu no mercado da publicidade
propaganda ela se tornou basicamente uma
ferramenta de venda agressiva violenta
impondo inclusive valores ações cumprir
faça seja mesmo a gente não sendo ea
gente acabou multiplicando isso nas
redes sociais
a gente acabou trazendo essa energia
para as nossas mídias digitais porque
hoje com a revolução tecnológica a
comunicação digital está em nossas mãos
porque nós estamos conectados através
dos nossos elaborá-los celulares quem
determina também o processo de
comunicação somos nós
então por que a gente não desenvolver um
pouco de afeto porque é também a gente
não percebeu o outro porque a gente não
trabalhar com a comunicação não violenta
esse é o termo vindo da psicologia que
quem trouxe o macho
o psicólogo americano que teve uma
infância um pouco violento
o chill e ele cresceu em querendo
entender como pessoas que passaram por
circunstâncias o xis e violentas
conseguiam desenvolver relações
afetuosas obviamente ele foi pra
faculdade de psicologia e mais ou menos
na década de 60 e 70 nos estados unidos
elevou a técnica para escolas e
faculdades americanas
não sei se vocês lembram mas foi mais ou
menos nessa época que o estado estava
polarizado e cheio de ódio brancos e
negros brigavam os panteras negras
tentava igualar os direitos entre negros
e brancos crise racial marcha e entendeu
que a cnv a comunicação não violenta é
uma ferramenta de afeto para conseguir
reduzir a crise e as dores das pessoas é
um termo vindo da psicologia mas ele
pode ser aplicado também na nossa
comunicação nas nossas redes sociais com
o primeiro ponto a observar sem
julgamento
há que apontar com a sacada disso gente
a sacada supersimples é praticar a
empatia até amor é se colocar no lugar
do outro lembra da luiza
pois é eu percebi ali que a forma dela
se comunicar por a mogi
eu me coloquei no lugar dela e também
comecei a me comunicar por ano hoje
percebi o sentimento de luisa
me coloquei no lugar de manaus à beto mg
era uma certa vergonha pela falta de
oportunidade não consegui me comunicar
com palavras me deu me deu um pouco de
vergonha por eu não consegui incluir
socialmente talvez mais votos ap
resolveu pt no desapego e resolveu o
problema de luiza e gerou o processo de
comunicação fluida atendendo à
necessidade da fala
esses são os três pontos da comunicação
não violenta e o que é que a gente
desenvolve com isso
como eu falei há pouco empatia
sabe aquela história que a gente
aprendeu na escola com a professora
respeito coleguinha
a gente sabe a gente já fez o dever de
casa assim sabe perfeitamente como
funciona a gente está colocando no lugar
do outro nas redes sociais um dia a dia
a gente inclui pessoas
a gente consegue entender os diferentes
a gente respeita a diversidade
diversidade essa que faz parte da gente
também não sei se vocês já pararam para
pensar mas em algum momento da vida a
gente vai precisar talvez de alguma
ferramenta de acessibilidade
a gente pode perder a visão de uma hora
pra outra
a gente pode perder a fala a gente pode
perder os han
a gente pode ficar sem caminhar por um
tempo o nosso layout pode mudar a gente
pode engordar e emagrecer
a gente vai envelhecer ea gente vai
precisar de acolhimento de compreensão
ea gente vai precisar de relações
empática a comunicação não violenta é
revolução e afeto afecto à fé
já pensou que a revolução pode estar na
palma de sua mão no ser humano de vocês
já pensaram nisso ea luiza a luiza é
muito além do que se vê gente por conta
da luiza eu voltei para a comunicação ea
luiza fez a revolução em mim muito
obrigado
[Aplausos]